what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg ann i'm john we are
here today to watch
the gray man a movie directed by them
russo brothers who do the avengers
movies and cherry and also stars uh ryan
gosling returning to the big screen one
of my favorite actors of all time
representing today and chris evans of
course looking like he's having a good
time this movie has a hundred and eighty
percent on rotten tomatoes right
movie it's gonna get all million of
those people back on netflix can't wait
but i'm excited man it looks like a
really fun action movie let's see maybe
it'll deliver just a tad bit more with
some good star-studded performances
including that honor day armist ladies
and gentlemen if you can leave a like i
know you can that would be so
appreciated also subscribe click the
notification bell covering a lot more
movies here on the channel full length
reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code available for them
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page cover a whole bunch of shows and
movies over there where the same tier
you get the option for reaction
highlights and watchdogs included for
some exclusive content and the prepper
team thank you for helping us edit down
these highlights
i'm excited let's get into action people
[Music]
i like honey buns as much as the next
guy i'm not going to guide your eye out
for whatever
you want some gum
bubblicious watermelon wave what do you
say whoa he looks weird
that swoop of hair
that
de-aging born 1980 incarcerated in 1995
eligible for parole in 2031.
i think the goatee threw me my name is
donald fitzroy and i'm here to commute
your sentence
what's the catch
you work for us who's asked
the c.i.a
you'd be part of an elite unit let's see
our program
you'd exist in the gray agreement
how long have i got to work for you
let's just say you'd be indefinitely
useful
i know everything about this character
now
[Laughter]
exposition
yeah i am on board
as a ci slave
damn
[Music]
so this took place last year
[Laughter]
2021 is very important
[Music]
he was just a wild rebellious cowboy
that was a cold cold-hardened c.i.a
agent
i don't have a permit it's not that kind
of party
it's an interesting choice to like tune
out all the audio in this room yeah just
focus on them
undercover of the party
ooh
cool guys scar
our target codename dining car is
selling information that can severely
compromise national security please
explain to me why i'm talking to a
sierra agent instead of somebody within
our circle of trust six was in the
region and he happens to be historically
good at the church that's a good ham
wakes in this this is a star-studded
cast
it's almost as if netflix has disposable
income
[Music]
why am i not hearing anything i'm
picking up collateral
there's a kid near the mark got code man
shoot the kid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stand by do not stand by
[Applause]
he knows someone's about to shoot him
that one guy for the
[Music]
wardrobe nice that was awesome
i like subtle [ __ ] like that
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
they didn't tell you who i am today
they never do
i'm sierra four
i would have sent you out to kill one of
your own
that's probably not gonna make you walk
away is it
no it's gonna lead to a badass fight
oh ouch
if you're sierra who recruited you when
did he button his suit back up
same as you
i got all the answers because i'm
telling the truth
they're not
it's like a graphic novel vibe to this
that's a good way to put that
hey
take this
and bring the bastard down
i don't want it
you drove the car michael
hey kids
i don't want no part of this [ __ ]
there you go i took it okay you give him
hell six
ah
six is feeling some pain honor among
assassins what about pocket litter
to get anything off his body
did he have anything on his person
that you now have
that you like to give to me
that you just closed up and put in your
pockets
carmichael's been calling
we
spoke you should go without me
tell me what i don't know
[Music]
well that's the problem isn't it there's
a lot of movie in these last 10 minutes
i know
it's all the movie all at
the once brothers to distinguish
themselves minimize their text
instead of the whole screen
now there's a big one and a little one
context why is it always the last stall
al capone booth i can see everything
from here
he blew off his ex-film
[Laughter]
lloyd hansen is a sociopath he has
methods sociopathic methods so sit on
him the guy has a higher kill count the
entire mossad i don't need lloyd's
stable i need him effective
this is like a 90s action movie with the
sheen of a modern-day action film
mr c.i.a you devil
and the jumper cable to somebody else i
got an urgent locate and destroyed give
me a name sierra 6. that could be fun
the man's got some street cred make him
gone does the old man know about this
not yet
head's a role
[Laughter]
give me fitzroy's file we'll find
somebody he loves and
squeeze
do me right lloyd
have i ever done you wrong danny
this movie's in a rush to get someone i
know
you were the one who lost the asset in
the first place and you couldn't get it
back the last person that pissed off the
old man ended up floating in the potomac
if you like
breathing
you might want to fix this
that's just the most assured
cool ass villain in his own mind
[Laughter]
needs anything
just a nap he's just so cool calm and
collected meeting me in berlin i'm
supposed to be in singapore not anymore
[Music]
russo brother's kind of gone a little
michael bay-ish haven't they how's it
been i was literally about to say
in the like pacing and the
money-shotting of everything yeah
remind me hansen how long did you last
at the agency six months five and a half
so how's the private sector treating you
to pay as well as they say or do you
spend most your time strangling cats who
likes cats i like cats i like cats i
like cats let's talk about the mess your
boy made and judging by your shallow
breathing and puckered [ __ ] i can
only assume you know why i'm here
you know i can't find him because his
file doesn't exist but your file
well that's chock full of nuggets now i
tried to get her to smile but uh
you know kids
like an actual selfie oh my god
[Laughter]
i'm really loving uh chris evans so far
[Music]
plane fight
plane crash i want him terminated
come again
keep the body in everything he has on
his person
just make it painless what damn
ryan gosling was trained to hear phone
calls while in flight
[Music]
that's smarter sneak up on the special
agents
man we all just want to talk
this is the fireworks and flares movie
it's a mummy reference
best trailer of all time
is there a wilhelm scream in there
wow they trained him for anything he
so in the moment he's just like yep i'm
grabbing this and i got air here
[Music]
[Music]
this is some wild ass [ __ ]
i'm like overwhelmed right
[Laughter]
he's doing it
do the thing do the thing when you put
your hands to your side make yourself
aerodynamic yeah fall faster
wow
interesting
he dove choked him
used the parachute yeah sufficient jason
bourne [ __ ] is that is that the big game
franchise like a blinking just cause
just oh like uh yeah the games yeah yeah
that's what i'm kind of thinking of when
i watch this [ __ ] yeah
it's like cracked out
hello
it's me
where are you
emotionally
[Laughter]
they're my niece
you hear me
hold on you're breaking up
[ __ ]
hello
hello
okay there you are so many flashbacks
well why don't you come on in and we can
chat my assistant will get lunch you
like sushi no i'm good i
just had some skittles
you can give me the asset you stole and
i won't have to chop your head off
headquarters needs a scapegoat and his
neck is just about the right size he
knows what business he's in
he lawyers
yeah i immediately don't like you
six as well is pretty natural compared
to yours
don't say peter natural to me
it's an [ __ ]
your boy won't be able to walk 10 feet
without getting his head blown
and that dog is exactly what bad ethics
and zero impulse control will
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a
alt universe where rob cordrey played
chris evans
[Laughter]
yes absolutely
here's a photo of rob cordray in case
you don't know who rob court bluff rob
cordray yeah
okay six
fits tell him why he's here no way the
cast gets bigger i am a niece that i'm
raising someone in the dc office has
accidentally leaked fitz's address in
hong kong not your idiots fitz is
starting a mission in brazil tomorrow
which means you are going to babysit oh
so he's got a personal connection to
this little girl
i like your tattoo
what's it mean
the writing this guy's name in greek
what guy just a guy you know trying to
get a rock up a hill
why they made them
who made him yes the gods they need a
rock
i just i try to punish him i think did
he deserve it probably
you ask a lot of questions you're quite
the conversationalist
i'm gonna get back to work
shooter
oh
i want to buy an audi
something yeah
just struck me
the remote system flagged at 10 minutes
before he pulled up we can keep track of
her pacemaker from just about anywhere
thank you
he's a very smart man
the only family i got closest thing to
family i got too
maybe that kind of makes us family
huh this just got personal
music to set the action scene fine young
hipster
[Music]
look at those caustics
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
this is cool seeing ryan gosling just
like a full-on
action sure you're all right
it's just another thursday you should go
to bed
sleep peacefully
[Laughter]
how up i got dry cleaning nine
espionage
i could have watched the whole movie
about him in that little girl yeah i was
really enjoying that
space let me make like a side sequel
this will be a minute
i'm getting that
i think you should go get yourself
cleaned up before we take your pictures
unless bloody and beaten is the kind of
look you're going for
maybe it'll make it easier to get
through customs just what this guy looks
like
damn wowie buffy is ken
i know
this is all in service of his kenroll
you need an alias
and it has to be something very very
easy to forget you can step in the world
something like you know
john
joe hon pablo is also a very common name
mohamed is the most commonly used name
on earth
the desired response is emotion
right you know hope anger
can you give a step towards me please
there's some hypnotic thing happening
yes
i'm gonna trigger your secret training
emotional memory has
staying power
you know all about notoriety
don't you
whoa
what the [ __ ] what a great trap set up
yeah
that's a legit trap door
leads into a [ __ ] well
yeah i never even met six until i landed
in bangkok
and no one said anything about a
retrieval what's the asset do you know
where six is no
macgyver
six is the last of the dirty half
doesn't and he is 100 conforming to
pattern
he hurts people
because that's who he is
that's here protecting this guy's so
unlikable i know
am i jarring your memory yet
you can see the reflection in his retina
[Music]
by an audio
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's just every cool action guy let's
put a very specific trap
where's the target where's my money
oh
every skill
in the book
it just so calmly hits everyone i don't
know
it's a methodical
oh here we go
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Laughter]
how much [ __ ] chris happens is that
[Music]
nice try pumpkin what's the issue are
you why
you want my foot in your ass ah [ __ ]
[Laughter]
looks like an 11.
who's this one
wasn't she in berlin
i get the sense that travel time doesn't
mean a lot in this movie
not the trunk get in i could really use
a comfortable chair right now
honored armist is so cool i know man
she is blowing up this almost feels like
a sequel to a character from no time to
die
unless you want our names spilled across
every news alert on every phone in every
pocket on earth shut up and go sit in
the corner
too
how about that
forget about the viking
why are you walking like that
because i got shot in the ass suzanne
[Laughter]
you're just an asset but it's my career
my reputation why did you steal
technically i didn't steal anything ford
gave it to me then white didn't you give
it to hq no she gave it to me
they already had me kill an agent now
it's my turn how do you know you're not
next
you didn't draw that conclusion get
comfortable
we're about to get into a car chase
get comfortable like we're going to
prague or
a jail comfortable
drones are a thing
that we can use now
[Laughter]
because sure
where'd she drive over the curb for
there's someone in prague that
he trusts the most who is that that's
your mother boring
ah wow now
whatever i just did to your ears it's
not even torture
i just made it up on the spot just came
to me
[Laughter]
not a bad strategy
oh yeah
yes
let's do it
i don't want to watch
[Music]
should we try again
okay fine i could do this all day
who's here
i already told you i don't know
[Music]
maybe we should get the girl back in
here
[Music]
he must legit cut something out of that
car scene
you did say you were gonna quit it was a
life of few pleasures i clung to the
ones i had was three months
optimistic
if you utter anything remotely
sympathetic i will shoot you
she aged so much in the last two years i
know
a whole new look and everything got a
hold of some evidence
tried selling it to the highest bidder
carl michael got wind of it
and used six to take him out
big mistake there's no way we can copy
the file it's a dead disk it's been a
while since i've seen a movie that's
based around action scenes
yeah right
how do we most inventively get to the
next one fast
like how he knew that that was there
where is he where is who
the hell is she doing oh no
she's gonna blow you all away
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he tried getting back in there to save
her well that was unexpected
did we just kill margaret cahill
the cia doesn't know what they're doing
it does seem like like no one's paying
attention to anything happening with
them
send everyone get them in there every
team light it up
this is one ambitious ass cop
not
[Music]
today please just do it stay still come
on man
you have my permission to shoot anyone
standing in his way
he's such a cartoon but he's so good
make him dead
he's a hero
oh [ __ ] now we're getting some winter
soldier vibes
sick of this
[Laughter]
margaret cahill wasn't enough
just gonna kill all the cops
you'd think
all of our teams are going to kill each
other
just shoot the bus
would someone mind shooting the man
handcuffed to the bench
now you got to get everybody who he
cleared out first
[Music]
not bad
not a bad gag
oh my god
[Laughter]
it's so insane
i love
[Music]
this yes thank you
extra 10 million to the first guy to put
a bullet in this kendall's brain
negative we lost him
nicely done there's a lot about this
that really feels like a video game yeah
or stuff you do in a video game it's
like time crisis i'm correct
yeah
time crisis is like a random online
component so there's just maximum
players and maximum chaos
[Applause]
damn it's nuts
oh [ __ ]
oh my god
[Applause]
wow
this is definitely the most entertaining
this movie's been yes
oh my god nice shot
it takes all these people to kill this
one cool calm collected guy
that's how cool and calm he is he's just
so in the moment he's prepared for
everything
[Music]
clever that is a boss move
the boss ass move
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
and then just a crater opens and the
city falls into it
thanks
[Laughter]
all teams report status this is quite
possibly the most spectacular failure
in the history of covert ops
[Laughter]
the most
look at that just
tracking the target
no change lone wolf get me that asset
what i do can't beat
that dude looks very familiar he's
another that guy this movie is full of
that guys tell me in the comments who he
is
she's got a pacemaker you don't have a
handcuff key do you
he could do everything but get himself
out of america
sir figure it out with the paper clip i
just can't do it i missed lock picking
day
i think he's actually a famous actor in
like international films yeah
probably gotta get that crossover
yeah seriously tell me who he is not in
croatian
we need a ride i call not trunk
ouchy
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
you made it more powerful
choose me
just burst through a hospital window
like that
[Music]
[Applause]
the hospital window won't cut you
okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
these drone shots are sometimes really
crazy
it's like a
amusement park yeah
you gave me an empty gun the shells were
coming you ran away and you need to say
hey wait that's empty i'm gonna bleed
out while we have this conversation i'm
just gonna
pack it and wrap it and we can go how
many wounded criminals have walked into
a vet's office
in real life
i want a list you probably count on one
hand
he started laying into my brother
so hard
it was clear it was either going to be
my brother or him
so
kyle i decided it would be him
ryan ryan
brain fog so he was never really a bad
guy that's why you're not like all the
others bob we're spa
i do all right all right you got me it's
let's do
good question
you're 42 regular
[Laughter]
knows the value of a good suit
tell me suzanne is there any other part
of your job that i can do for you
failing upwards does not qualify as
success no success qualifies as success
if you're you're a white guy failing out
birds does
[Applause]
wow every fight scene is so big
[Laughter]
the biggest that's not the only way
these people
operate and do not pay this [ __ ]
why they have all those missiles and
[ __ ] outside the gate
[Music]
wow
i love it
[Laughter]
give me eyes on the bridge
cool that's a really cool shot
you ready
that is the subtlest action this movie
is
[Music]
he's in the house
they got really excited about these hd
drones yep
man
make good edits
[ __ ]
it's kind of crazy they got jessica
hemlock who doesn't play a tough person
at all
really playing against type
take this give me a hand grenade do you
understand me go
[Music]
wow
that can't be good for the pacemaker 99
of her character is a pacemaker
[Laughter]
no don't kill her i like her
she's a gem
you douche
yo this guy's the [ __ ] man
yeah
the best fights are given to this guy
grace
oh man
god even though slight flourishes
his physicality he also brings like a
charisma
take it
i don't care about the money anymore
these are not honorable people
take it
interesting
i only do honorable
murders
i got a code
[Music]
[Laughter]
please don't shoot
who could you get to my hand
[Music]
of course one of these would be here
you need a good mage
keep him showdown
i have line of sight
you're gonna throw me that gun
or the little one gets a new face
if your strategy relies on whether or
not i'll kill a child you need a new
strategy
whoa
wow
face maker you have been a pebble in my
shoe since the very beginning
and now i just don't think i can walk
away guess what i'm thinking right now
that you've over shared
[Laughter]
my friend's gonna meet you at the edge
of the maze okay no no
yeah wait i'm not just gonna leave you
here with him it's crazy
no no we're gonna take you with me
[Music]
no problem this is just another thursday
go
okay
you got this now for some reason six is
gonna get like
beat up a tad bit here
yeah when he normally would
but it's the final fight you gotta have
you gotta give up a few
or not phil might surprise me
ah
do you miss your fingers
still getting used to it
[Music]
[Applause]
ouch
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
he's just a guy who's uh occasionally
frustrated
[Music]
oh damn this is reminding him of his
childhood
[Music]
prepared him for this moment
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
finally suzanne
a character arc
and you are
bad news is you'll probably get your old
cell back but the good news is if you
behave i'll let you out to play
sometimes
[Music]
he grew
or something
he completed a
traumatic circle
[Laughter]
sort of
[Music]
we're just gonna blame it on the guy we
hired
if anything ever happens to claire
fitzroy
deals off
i will comfort you
please
remove yourself from my personal space
oh equality
it's been unresponsive the last few days
he just lays there can't tell if his
scythes are medical
won't eat
speed won't even look at us brain damage
he shows up on the skin
starving himself to death
[Music]
satisfied it's our official earmuffs
song started
killing right at the right time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's chris evans
twist
am i allowed to chew gum in here
[Music]
[Applause]
how did he know it doesn't matter he
know he's the best he knows the degree
man he can find anything i'm the green
man
it's just over okay
yep and you see he had the dark gray
pants but the lightest gray jacket to
signify his change
all righty
well
i'll be honest with you guys
it's been a half hour since we watched
this movie so we realized
that this audio you guys can hear
stopped recording
and uh about like an hour into the movie
and then we had to
problem solve fortunately we had some
backup audio no it didn't sound as good
in the last uh half of this reaction
because it was literally like right
around the halfway point of this film
but it sounds better than no audio at
all true and uh i'm still i'm still
personally recovering i'm like oh man it
really like took the wind out of me on
that one i'm not gonna lie it really
took the wind out of me the last thing
that's last first impression you want to
have had as the credits roll on
something as wild and rambunctious like
oh man the audio is bad yeah it's like
it's like putting a pin through a
balloon and just listening to it fizzle
out you're like oh
but we uh we have to focus up here
and just give an honest review right now
um for this film which was
i thought it was entertaining i thought
it was a lot of fun
um
although
it's kind of a mixed bag for me you know
it's definitely it's definitely a mixed
bag
it fluctuates
it fluctuates
yeah cause
it's like the end credits scene was kind
of the thing that really
like sort of summarized my feeling on
the movie
of
i think they think they made a movie
that feels like that but it doesn't
because when it's not
it it's weird like there's a lot of
scenes
that
just uh play just so it's so generic
like it's wildly generic i was surprised
by this is so generic
and
so straightforward in
the kind of movies that it's
being like
and
that was probably the quality that i was
surprised by the most because look what
rocks about this film i think it's
really obvious what's great about this
movie
the action is top-notch it's just
[ __ ] bonkers
it's it's wild it's insane
was that prague the big crazy one with
the that they always teased in the
trailers that was in the where everyone
in the city all the baddies come
together to just kill everyone just have
a
[Music]
and here we go and there are even notes
of the purge in there yeah they're just
gonna slaughter everyone in sight
they're gonna have cool skull masks
while they're doing it uh chris evans
was insanely entertaining like he was
he he was just having a ball of a time i
like maniacal chris evans um dinosh was
kind of a surprising scene stealer
because he doesn't have like he's not
given a lot of lines but
he felt like such a highlight i think i
liked
his style of fight scenes the best
because that's when it was just like
not all [ __ ] like sensory overload
and and it was just so like brutal
and well choreographed
you know i thought he was great i liked
ana de armas
um i liked uh i mean ryan gosling he he
was really cool he was a cool guy you
know he weirdly pulled it off i'm not
going to lie in the first
20 or 30 minutes i was going
not so sure how i'm feeling about ryan
gosling in this movie yeah
um but then as the movie went i think he
made the right choice
of because he's kind of he's kind of
this hodgepodge of like a [ __ ] ton of
action characters from
from cinema and video games
you know he's just all of them
and because he's got that
ridiculous
cool calm guy who just kind of gets a
little frustrated from more like a 70s
or 80s action hero yeah it was like he's
a little tired of this but but he's
gonna get a good do a good job and get
the job done yeah but he's also this
like relentless force who's just gonna
knock it out of the park all the time
yeah yeah with like the most ruthless
efficiency but also you know like a
flare for theatrics to some degree
yeah because you know capturing the kind
of style of acting that ryan gosling
usually brings to the table which is so
subtle and and very internal which
complements very well off of the kind of
performance chris evans is actually
giving which is so much like literally
mustache twirling
chewing yeah yeah he's just having so
much fun and they represent two shades
of this film
so i think in terms of your main
antagonist and your protagonist i
actually think
that the way those two chose to play it
worked really well for this film because
his ryan gosling's performance really
started clicking for me
i mean like in terms of an emotional
part when the first time he's meeting
the daughter
um
but it was like the crazy action scene
where it starts off handcuffed to the
bench he's just getting like a little
slightly vexed at situations you know
and then the way how chris evans is
going like why didn't one to shoot the
one guy in the bench like the way they
were handling that was really well
edited and timed and funny but exciting
and and ryan gosling remaining like cool
common collected like pretty much from
like beginning
this whole
thing uh because you know it is playing
this
it is playing this like empty
individual who has become so hardened
and cold but it it also
to to portray an action character to
that caliber
of superheroism
yeah
you know he
he weirdly struck that right note for me
of
i guess if you were this capable in
handling this amount of craziness
like you were just this skilled there's
something really
humorous
and
well like this seems like the believable
way to have done it in a weird way it's
a weird way it worked it's like this
cannot be a real person yeah thus you
cannot take it the same kind of
seriously you would in like various
other ryan gosling performances you
could point to regardless of how
heightened whatever movie is i i feel
like yeah there he brings this all that
commitment but i think what makes
because i was sitting there too thinking
okay is this is this gonna be a little
it's like there are a bunch of movies
you can point to that ryan gosling's
been in that would make you go yeah he
could star in a movie like this easily
but this also requires a certain amount
of that you know like rugged you know
one linery abandon that you don't
necessarily associate with him but i
feel like yeah it's he applied the right
amount of like he's clearly taking it
seriously but i think he knows the kind
of lightness it's almost like countering
chris evans with something that seems
very aware of itself but also still
understated somehow yeah yeah i think he
was still in the
he
sometimes because at first i was i was
starting to think
okay is ryan gosling perhaps
not in the same movie that this movie is
sure at first i was kind of i was sort
of in a playground like that
but then it started to like really work
for me and when i was like oh i'm really
getting this performance down yeah and
he's got a lot of rhythm i mean for as
much as he is like there are way bigger
characters around him half the time he
does have like a good sense for the
rhythm of this
you know he's laconic but there's also
that fast back and forth he has with a
lot of people it's he's just as
methodical and how he deals with
characters as he is you know killing
them yeah because he's not he's got the
skill level that seems to surpass john
wick in many ways um but he's got the
he's got everything he's got his spy
human abilities he's got the human
strength ability and healing ability and
mobile ability of like a fast and
furious character yeah so it's like they
took like a john wick character threw
him into die-hard situations
with the strength of like a fast and
furious character
with the yeah imperviousness to insane
carnage the fast and furious character
has to have and the insane like
durability
although i mean he sells it better than
half those movies he sold it like i i
really started to believe like i
actually believe this guy has this
like unstoppable lethal weapon and
that's the thing is you've seen this
character like a hundred billion times
and you can see all the influences
but to his
two
yeah to his credit it does feel like he
does have his own personality even
though you can feel all the characters
that inspired this character yeah and uh
chris evans same same note like yeah
just on a very opposite
side of the whole equation uh chris
evans really brought that i wish we did
get more scenes
uh solely between them i would have
liked that just a little bit more scenes
between them
and uh i i did like on a day arm i
wasn't anything like him and ryan
gosling had like electric chemistry or
anything like that uh i thought they
played off each other just fine
and
you know i really like ryan austin's
performance in the last half after that
sequence and then you know when he
fights the news and he's like super
injured you know because he was just so
impervious to like pain it seemed like
before that i did find myself going oh
yeah you know sometimes in fight scenes
and characters like this i like it when
it's kind of like an uphill physical
battle for them like like john wick or i
think of like daredevil you know those
kind of characters where it's just
it is
it becomes physically more of a toll on
them as it goes how battered can this
guy get yeah but still keep going but he
never never truly like leaned fully into
that in this movie and nor do i think
they wanted him to
um i think because the movies is such
it's so
it seems like it takes itself seriously
in the dialogues other than when they're
going for jokes
um
it seems like it takes itself pretty
serious in in the in the
non-action scenes for the most part
these are serious stakes life is on the
line but it feels like
cheesy
yes in the middle portion a tad boring
yes um
and uh but then it would have like just
ridiculous action that was just so
that
it felt like this movie was constructed
to just get to the action scenes all the
time yeah totally well and that's the
thing is then you look at the rest of
the movie and i mean i'm sure it's there
you know i'm sure if we go watch it back
there's there's some dialogue but like
the cia operation
and just the organization as it's
depicted here that is kind of
responsible for all this it just seems
like
what purpose do you see like these are
like your own guys in different ways
that you're just sending after each
other and destroying like so like it did
remind me of die hard five at a certain
point where i was like you have
destroyed
terrorist levels of
like property here
and yeah it's sort of like the cia
feels like a very small insulated thing
rather than like this
organization that you know taps
intelligence and manipulates you know
the country and the world so
it does feel like a cartoon in the rest
of everything
but there's two kinds of cartoons
like one cartoon feels very intentional
and the other cartoon doesn't feel as
intentional like i think it wanted to be
intense at times i think it wanted to
actually have an intriguing mystery
and an intriguing world
and it never did it never quite did like
i was never
i never found it like
intense and it was exciting just by the
sheer volume of the [ __ ] insanity of
a video game it would become with its
action scenes um but in between that
like like to me personally i i generally
feel that you know if you're not gonna
really
you you need you need scenes that
support the action or the action should
support that
and
here
that's where i'm like oh man you got all
these great actors here this should be
really elevated
and it never felt like it was like the
actors did elevate it they did like
without these great actors
would have just been a doll fest for
sure yeah um
but they did elevate it but then part of
me was thinking like maybe you should
just kind of committed to just a fun
tone throughout it maybe it should have
just been aiming to be solely a fun
time throughout because i i saw one
wrong tomatoes capsule in the time that
i was like
fuming over the freaking audio
um because i was like what did people
actually think about this and there was
one artist i couldn't agree with
which was um this movie doesn't want you
to take some something about that i was
like this movie doesn't want you to take
anything this is like a positive
recommendation uh one of the
uh you know fresh ones uh of you doesn't
want doesn't want you to take anything
seriously i'm like i don't know about
that i think it does i think yeah i
think it does and that's what it would
drag
well yeah because because of the way
that it is kind of torn between i feel
like you can look at the action as a
microcosm and see that it's competing
with itself in being the really harsh uh
like really you can feel the physicality
and it's like all these like intense
long takes and you can tell the actors
really threw down for the combat
training yeah but then
the circumstances however realistically
they are portrayed in terms of just
physics and carnage are like so
ridiculous that they the two do kind of
clash
and yeah there's not good enough writing
around the real stakes or the real
motivation it's not a real it's not it's
bad writing around the espionage
thriller aspect
yeah and but there is that thing of like
yeah i think the the grittiness of
certain elements even though heightened
like does i don't know like i thought
they anytime you have somebody's niece
or whatever get kidnapped i think they
want you to care and and the part of the
movie that was the most endearing was
them together well they have this whole
thing with like let's flash we do these
like random flashbacks that i saw on the
cherry trailer yeah
and uh
i didn't see the actual cherry movie but
i was like this looks like the cherry
trailer but yeah when they have a
flashback of showing oh my god this like
because i was i was so
mixed on this whole thing with
understanding six's past
of like cutting to it of why are we even
bothering to explore any of this to be
totally honest i have no idea why we're
doing any of that it has two
recognizable actors and it's so heavy
like there's cigarette burns on
on your forearms and he beat the brother
and i killed my dad it's like all these
like super
heavy things
that don't really seem to amount like i
guess it's supposed to be i was i found
myself just questioning it of like i
guess they're trying to
um
pull back like oh in the beginning of
the movie we we had you fooled this was
a bad guy
but no
who saw that
he had a he had a righteous purpose i
mean is that the intention because
even when it cuts to
the you know he's drowning and he's
thinking of his dad like i i don't know
what this amounts to and i guess in the
end he's a he's a dad now this is just
one is that whatever
that's what it is in the end right he's
gonna be a dad to her and now he's gonna
not do what like i don't
he's gonna live a peaceful life
and just people are gonna follow them
around the globe trying to kill the both
of them and he's gonna kill everyone
tries to kill that i mean it's messy
it's a messy film it's a really
expensive messy movie that um
that uh
i like i i'm not gonna lie like i i i
had f i had i was pretty much amused
from beginning to end other than a few
parts and i'm like okay this part's
boring
this part's starting to drag you well
that's the thing is it's it's paced like
a movie that wants you to take it a
little more seriously
or not paste i'm sorry it's the length
of a movie that yeah you take it a
little worse but it's also like in such
a rush and i
i yeah like i didn't really care about
like anyone or anything like it didn't
really matter not like nothing mattered
you know it was just about watching like
cool action scenes and occasionally
being charmed by some acting yeah it's
like it's fun it's impressive at moments
the costumes and the locations are
beautiful and and yeah it's one of those
[ __ ] discover drones and we're like
we're using the great possibility just
looking look how cool this drone shot is
my god we're swooping and it's creating
crazy edits and stuff yeah i mean at
times it doesn't even serve it at times
it's just it's kind of distracting to me
yeah and i mean i feel like you know
especially subjective arguments have to
do with style over substance but early
on i was thinking like these are really
cool settings and they're fighting
amongst fireworks and there's like a
smoke bomb
like there's so many cool and
interesting things that are like
semi-motivated by the fact that like
you know they need this for cover or
he's you know got a lot of cool and
interesting things to fight with but
more than anything they just look cool
and they're somebody they they feel in
the moment like somebody going uh what's
an inventive way we can have a fight
scene now what have we not done yet and
so yeah it's like luckily a lot of that
stuff is inventive and a lot of it's
captured really cool like you said
michael bay and the first act i kept
sitting there thinking this does feel
like a michael bay movie and that
everything is like check out how cool
every kind like no shot is not kind of
informed by like check out how cool and
intense this is and and yeah it manages
to balance that energy with again the
really good cast
and so it's one of those things where i
get it like it's a summer romp where you
don't need to take
too many things seriously but i think
the things it wants you to take
seriously are going to be the factor for
people and whether they like it or not
no i mean at the end of the day
most of the run time is scenes and
there's only and most of the runtime is
not action even though you might walk
away thinking of that yeah it's not most
of the runtime so i'm like well most of
the runtime definitely needs to be
improved
yeah and i'm shocked because of who they
have
the entire collaboration of writing and
directing they've made some great films
and so to see that this is what was
delivered upon writing especially
uh was shocking um in that regard
because i i really felt that
once we did get to that scene where he
breaks out where where he is handcuffed
to the bench and all that like
okay this is great like that was really
great and then and
and then it i thought it was gonna like
kind of like maintain this and go
this is really clicking for me this is
really working because i was just so
intermittent for me of
of really enjoying some scenes and then
really just not enjoying like just going
like this is just a kind of a weird film
that falls flat a lot of the time no
matter how bombastic it is um it would
fall it would definitely fall flat and i
i i am conflicted on my feelings uh
for it because even i'm like looking at
raw tomatoes i'm like it's at 51
currently
so it's like what 50
side do i fall on and i'm like i'm kind
of
in the middle of that 50
yeah
i wonder what this would be like on a
re-watch because there's a lot that's
appealing the first time around but but
i mean yeah you look at marcus mcfeely
co-writing this together and
you think this is also based on source
material which i i don't know how much
has changed from that but it does
like the least interesting thing is the
actual circumstances of the spy
espionage like that whole opening scene
where he's talking to four and he gives
him the necklace
you're sitting there going you know
it's like i thought of the born identity
again in that moment because it reminded
me of the moment where he has the face
off with clive owen and it's
partly about it's a very similar scene
with like just way more it's the only
time you even see clive owens character
in that movie or out of a couple but
it's the only like real talk they have
and it's the same kind of thing where
it's like uh we're both kind of victims
of the same
that's not turning on you except you
didn't get to know the organization here
it's like you led with that scene
instead of putting it like halfway
through and then we get to know the
organization but really only through
this one guy and his assistant who's
annoyed with him yeah it's like they
they got to the plot so fast yeah they
were really rushing to it
like insert insert cut around while this
person's talking you know i have it
overlapped to a scene that's already
starting now uh you know jump around
through time a lot it was just it was
non-stop it just wouldn't it wouldn't
stop and then and i'm like well you
can't generate intensity without any
buildup to it uh at all and that's what
kind of
really sort of lacked for me because i
see a better movie and i wouldn't be as
perplexed with this
and i would just walk away going like
that's a solid entertaining ass fun time
but when i'm here going man i kind of
wish i didn't know who was involved in
this movie because if i didn't know who
was involved with this movie if i didn't
if it was just some random netflix movie
i watched i would expect to be sitting
here
you know it's not even a thought i had
until right now but but i think
that
you know with knowing this is netflix's
most expensive movie knowing the stars
knowing the writers knowing the director
that i i've i would have walked away
going
damn i should have seen this in the
theaters yeah yeah yeah or i'm like i'm
totally fine watching this at home
and that's a bummer because i mean there
are a couple like that that skydiving
sequence or you know skype falling
sequence uh is one of those things where
i was sitting there going man like i
can't i can tell there are some insane
effects and stunts mixing in and out i
would be fascinated to know what this
looks like on a big screen but at the
same time you complete the movie and
again yeah you look at all the resources
that went into it and all the people
involved and you think or i thought
man if this had been a titan if this
didn't care so much about certain things
and committed to being a tight 90
minutes or an hour and 45 even and just
used the the
most essential components almost and
played it even maybe a little more
simple and just kept
the action they wanted this could have
been that really satisfying blockbuster
what the dialogue scenes had like just
fun rhythm yeah fun characters yeah but
at times it played a little spoof-like
because at times it's like this that's
why i said rob cordray because i'm like
this feels like rob cordray to harold
and kumar escaped guantanamo bay like
that kind of cia story and then jessica
henwick's just like
always like pulling her hair out and
like losing her [ __ ] and it just felt
like a cartoon
in a way that at times i couldn't quite
tell if it wanted to be a cartoon in
those scenes or if it want to take
itself seriously because sometimes it
really felt like they wanted to take
itself serious
and and yeah and then you especially in
the fbi or cia side of it you're like
it's not
nuanced enough to be serious but it's
also not going overboard with the cheese
enough to like really be fun in spite of
what it's doing it's more just like you
said it feels like a 90s
you know
cia thriller character that's all evil
and all in control yeah and uh yeah it
it
it doesn't amount but it is really fun
in the moment and yeah you make you kind
of wish that they had gone you know what
the point is to watch chris evans and
ryan gosling go head to head and clash
those personalities together and let's
focus in on on that and there's plenty
of that there's a lot of that um i
didn't feel like there was enough but no
it's it is that thing once we got toward
the end even
as much as i don't have like two scenes
together yeah and as much as i don't
need this movie to be longer
like that and by the time we got to them
fighting at the end i felt like this
in the order of events i feel like this
should be like the fight number two out
of three or some kind of thing or or if
there had been another scene of just the
two of them together
talking you know intensely or you know
bouncing off each other for more yeah
like they feel oddly separate from each
other for how much this movie is selling
you their match up well the thing is
the problem with chris evans is
character as much fun as he's having
he's the furthest from intimidating he's
the furthest from
scary or imposing
you know like
not you you don't really i didn't even
feel a build up to them finally fighting
each other i didn't feel like he was as
good as they made him out to be no
everyone's just talking him up but they
also treat him like he's the biggest
dumbass on the planet and he is kind of
a dumbass because his whole plan is just
like i got every bunch of black ops
assassins i could find and i'm just
gonna throw them all at the same dude
they're all gonna kill each other and
the cops and then i'm gonna have to go
and he never really had scenes that
showed he was he was capable like they
kind of say like oh he got kicked out
but it would
he got kicked out after five and a half
months
um but i thought that meant like oh he
was just like too brutal for the cia
like he was too
too lethal but it was just like you're
you're an unhitched cartoon bulldog or
something like i don't know exactly know
what you are what kind of asset would
you be to anybody i guess other than
your ability to corral a bunch of other
people to fight for you because that
movie doesn't ever show you
like
why he
i'm not saying why in terms of like
what's his backstory but we don't get
that flashback moment to be like let's
see a really good establishing scene of
this guy to really get us you know
feeling the dread or whatever for him
that they want us to feel like oh yeah
he's funny he's there's something really
funny about him um but you know he's the
one who could take down ryan gosling i
was like danish is the one who took that
right i was like
well and and yeah like that's that's the
funny thing is i almost feel like they
were afraid to make him too unlikable or
something and so he is
cartoonishly unlikable fun to watch but
i feel like the key to a character like
that is often including one or two
moments where they do cross the line
into ruthlessness and hate ability yeah
where you do see that oh they are the
one who is the one to fear or the one
you hate yeah or something like that but
it was uh it that's the problem with
that character is because
honestly like with what the writing is
i'm like now chris evans did it the best
yeah no i mean for what yeah for what's
there it's i couldn't ask for more but
also but there's a lot of problems
though with the way he's written that
don't help serve
this there's no for a movie as big as
this that also feels like it's there's
no stakes yeah and and i think that's
the biggest issue with it is
you got to have some stakes you just got
it you just got to have some stakes to
in any way
yeah because once you've seen the trick
it's like i feel like in the the first
viewing of this movie gets by on a lot
of whooshing and and you know physical
ingenuity like a lot of really
interesting like fun and crash bang
choreography and and there's a lot to
enjoy on on the surface there but yeah
once you come out of it you're like ah
there's
there's nothing really that you'd want
to revisit and and i guess the mystique
of the inventiveness wears off after the
first time you've seen it so what you
have to come back to
is just a bunch of pretty good action
and stuff like that but there's not
really a lot to
unpack
or really
you know dissect yeah i have no i i
don't really have an interest in
re-watching this movie no and i was like
[ __ ] ryan gosling's returning to the
screen yeah russo brothers chris evans
how did they harvest like
i i think you know the reason you get a
cast like this to sign up is knowing
who's directing the film so i i would
expect
i did expect something that i expected
to disagree with that 51
when i saw it i expected to be like oh
you know i'm one of the people that just
gets it yeah just have fun yeah put the
movie on it's level yeah you know but
very few know how to like bring the cool
action and then also keep the keep a big
life in between
and this lacks life in between and to
know how how much light because i can
hear i can imagine somebody hearing that
and saying it doesn't need to be deep
but that's i think the the art of things
like these is knowing just how deep like
john wick is not an especially deep
movie but it's got style and personality
and life and in between the action and
it has just the right amount of those
things to make you care about the right
characters and the right circumstances
to feel the stakes yeah it's like it's
just enough and it's not more or less
it's not trying to be more or less than
it absolutely needs to be and it
understands what it needs to do and how
and why and this has yeah a lot of
really cool moments a lot of really
interesting and fun sequences some nice
needle drops and things like that but
it's
the whole
is not as great as the sum of the parts
yeah yeah it's cause like with john wick
as one example when you get to the
action you're excited like oh here we go
whereas uh here you're it's a different
ooh it's it's like oh we could finally
be entertained yeah ryan gosling's gonna
find another creative solution probably
no problem for a minute that's the issue
with the writing of a character like
that and the capturing of a character
like that is you never feel like this
person's in danger it is that it's never
going to be that hard for them and every
plot hole gets fixed by you going well i
guess he's just that good
like i've enjoyed the humor of why'd you
throw me
why did you why didn't you throw me a
loaded gun like that's funny but that's
more for characters where you feel like
they're in a position
of really being like
they're they're going up against the
machine they're two people that they're
going up against all the odds in the
world and i'm like
this kind of felt it's weirdly felt out
of place for these two to be to have
that moment like i liked that scene i
thought it was funny i thought i think
the idea of arguing over
you don't throw it because that's such
an action movie trope to like you throw
a loaded gun and they get into the field
but i'll maybe go yeah maybe you don't
throw a load of guns there's so many
ways that would go wrong
yeah yeah so it's it is funny um but it
also felt like this belongs to
a different more different characters in
different movies yeah clever movie
thought of this yeah yeah and uh it's
like and if they had that kind of
tone where it's like he just keeps
slugging through life as as opposed to
the occasional
uh
right that's all he does to show like
ryan gosling is the is that
he's just yeah he's just kind of tired
of this [ __ ]
yeah throughout yeah like no matter how
insane or whatever is it's just yeah
like a
i know i'm gonna handle it this is gonna
suck you know that's how yeah
which is fun to again it's it's fun to
watch but it doesn't hold a lot of a lot
of weight and yeah like watching those
those sequences back and forth like
it's one of those things where i feel
like not every movie needs to be meta
and that kind of commentary in dialogue
can get obnoxious but i feel like if you
are doing a movie like this that does
have so much troping and so much
you know obvious borrowing and homaging
to a lot of other movies i feel like it
does help you in those certain sequences
and then
like i was if that
bit with the bench hadn't been so well
kind of my whole sequence from beginning
to end was so well done yeah yeah like i
i had a great time with that sequence
enough to have the thought
in my mind and go i don't really care
that i i i don't see how this would work
at all uh i i don't um
i had a train and it was going but oh
that that's what it was is i was sitting
there watching that sequence
and thinking to myself uh
uh
i don't know yeah there's no way
i had it it's gone
my articulate thought is gone i don't
know at times he was mr bean
like mr bean but capable like
part of me was wishing they just
committed like full steam ahead with
this guy is
like so unstoppable and he's constantly
cool in the face of danger and the other
guy is so maniacal like just go full
force with like he is
way too extremely cool yeah and like he
just can't be touched yeah and the
thought came back to the thought came
back to me is in that scene i had the
thought of uh
yeah it's like he is like he's lucky
he's like no one could shoot him yeah
yeah yeah exactly and in that moment i
had to i let go of it because the scene
was that good uh but it's it made me
have that thought damn ugh it came back
it's like fleeting again uh uh uh
say something and it'll hit me third
time
um yeah i don't know i thought it was
just uh i thought it was okay it was
like don't get me wrong there are scenes
that definitely warrant a good uh
reaction and a response and there are
dialogue i like ryan gosling's monologue
about his dad
and they
so yeah it was it was cool it was fun
yeah but i'm probably i don't really
have an interest in ever watching this
again
so no
that's what it is finally
chris evans is calling out why can't
anybody shoot this guy it's one of those
things where
at that moment almost came apart for me
because if it hadn't been so well
realized in every other faculty i would
have gone you're trying to cover up for
the fact that you have
created a scene where everyone's like no
this would be impo he'd be dead like
somebody would take that shot instead of
all the other shots and so yeah in the
moment it's it's well enough realized
that i was like that's fine i'll let go
of it but i think that's
for me a good indicator of how a lot of
this movie's experience is it's in the
moment you're like it's it's good enough
that i'm gonna let go of these concerns
but uh at the end that's gonna keep me
from coming back yeah but could care
less about billy bob thornton um hey he
showed up he's good
she's fine but i didn't care about him
no that's the big problem like when he
died i'm like yeah of course he's gonna
die it's pretty obvious
this exact scene would happen yeah this
exact thing
would happen
and because that's what happens to this
exact character and yeah
and i mean like they took me by surprise
with him at least one like one of the
more surprising turns when he does just
kind of give him up you know and there's
more to that but at the same time i'm
like i don't feel anything here because
i'm like i don't know these people
and then also they work through it and
it's kind of fine and they're just like
i don't know i guess that was the only
thing you could do and it's not going to
actually hold that much weight on
anything else yeah yeah like you wanted
to have some vague movies now are doing
all sorts of things about family and
it's all about found family right now
and and i feel like they could have done
that and they kind of do
but it's like you said in the middle
it's like i would have watched a movie
about him walking watching after this
girl because i'm like that's the only
time it has as generic as a [ __ ] plot
as that is like
you know
bad ass lethal assassin grey man's a
professional
care of little girl uh like you've seen
that movie a billion times yeah it was
easily the most engaging part in terms
of like this is the one thing one time
i'm kind of emotionally latched on to
this yeah so then it makes you go like i
wanted to see either a movie of that
scene or the sequel where it is just the
two of them well and then i think it
gets a little too caught up in trying to
be mystery revealing when i'm like but
you don't do a good job at building a
mystery you don't seem to care about
that yeah
i care about pacing like why do i give a
[ __ ] about
it's like what they try to show you is
oh he you know this whole thing with the
daughter the daughters like he can be a
dad and be the kind of dad that he never
had you know like he could do things
differently and protect her and this is
why he's uncomfortable around kids and
i'm like i think that's what they're
trying to say in the whole point of it
but
you you waited way too long to give any
hints about his backstory
to make me go oh that's what's going on
you know yeah totally
ah
um it's a mess it's a mess of a film and
it could have been great and if this was
not the people who
worked on it then i would have been like
another possible netflix movie and i'm
totally fine
but no i i i think i don't think it's
unreasonable to be like it could have
been more it could have been these are
the same people who made [ __ ] you
know winter soldier
where they had engaging ass scenes
when there wasn't cool action
and that would have intensity this aims
to be more fun and more
heightened with its action because
weirdly even though that's a superhero
movie this felt more ridiculous to me i
was sitting there in the first few
minutes going like i feel like you you
took some kind of spy thriller but
directed it like it's a friggin marvel
tent pole like everything's gotta be
like ratcheted up to 11. um
yeah
anyway that's just my thoughts yeah
what'd you guys think leave your
thoughts down below you can subscribe
if you want and uh yeah we'll catch you
all soon
marcus the leech mark leach how you
doing buddy we shouted you out last
month on a stranger things video and i
figured figured that that we got another
netflix event it's the perfect
opportunity then i started to think
about you buddy you because that's the
thing man you're such a sweet guy you're
such a supportive and creative cat
plus i mean you're living in the uk you
probably got a sweet ass accent you
would be the perfect
unsuspecting undetected
cia mole my friend because think about
it dude you
know the ins and outs of town and you
can keep it quiet you can lay low that's
your cover
but when the time comes you probably can
kick so much ass and the best part about
it is you're good with kids and as
everybody knows any good hitman assassin
badass type if you're good with kids
it's like the coolest iteration so dude
i want you to draw me a picture of
yourself
in your best like cia hitman you know
like shadowy past but not too shadowy i
want to see
your take on that and uh hey i hope
you're doing well uh i always love
seeing your face in the in the little
bubble that pops up here on patreon miss
you on agents of shield and uh and yeah
just hope you're doing well and we'll
talk soon much love buddy
[Music]